If my RGCC said my cancer did not respond to Ivermectin, does that mean I'm wasting my time doing Ivermectin and FedMed is all.
Not necessarily, I personally don't put a whole lot of stock in RGCC testing, but that's just me.
So if you're doing the RGCC test because you're putting stock in that test and then you're not doing what that test said to do, I'd question that.
But I also think that if you believe in your heart and you're thinking about it and praying about it, you feel led to do Ivermectin and FedMed is all that I think there's no nothing wrong with you doing that.
I wouldn't say you're wasting your time.
There's nothing wrong with experimenting with things like that.
Now this person that's asking this question has not been on RGCC for quite a long time, but I don't know what you've listened to my stuff on Ivermectin and FedMed is all.
But even today they said, if you're going to do Ivermectin and FedMed is all, you better be testing your liver enzymes in a regular basis like every two to four weeks.
Because you could have a spike and it can cause liver toxicity and you could have worst case scenario if you don't keep an eye on that and your liver enzymes go super, super high.
You could end up with liver failure and liver damage that could be very dangerous.
So you've got to be keeping an eye on that. That's my request to anybody who's doing FedMed is all at Ivermectin that you're testing that.
So I would say you test that.
And then you do a protocol and then you test, you know, if you can test for the benefits of that protocol, you test whether if it's a cancer that you could observe like it's a tumor in your breast, is it isn't improving?
No, it's not improving. It's doubled in size. Well, then maybe we need to change protocols.
If it's a cancer somewhere where you have to do a scan, well, that gets a little bit more complicated.
If it's cancer where you could view to the markers, that's a little bit easier. So that's how you'd assess whether it's working or not.